Такі колії по всій Україні – в бік кордону з ЄС
і в напрямку українських портів -
скрізь саме такі дороги.
Їх ремонтують щовесни,
а щоосені вони знов такі.
Все через перевантажені фури.
І саме перевізникам-порушникам держава готує сюрприз,
з яким водії ще не зіштовхувалися.
Сканери, камери, і головне ваги під новим асфальтом-
Усе це для автоматичної фіксації параметрів машини в русі.
зафіксована вага 42 тони 176 кг
Максимально допустима - 40 тон-
Ось на 5% перевищена допустима вага.
ширина 2.74 вона має бути 2.60 - не більше - по правилах
Це - система автоматичного контролю ваги в русі і вона фіксує,
які автомобілі порушують вагові та інші норми.
Датчики діють по всій ширині траси в обох напрямках.
Відповідно до нового закону про штрафування перевантажених фур
дані цієї системи будуть використовувати для накладання штрафів.
За номерним знаком ми би дізналися перевізника.
Отримали би інформацію з бази даних маршрутів,
якщо він погоджував свій переїзд,
щоб дізнатися яку відстань він проїхав.
Вираховуємо суму штрафу , формуємо документі  відправляємо.
Нові штрафи можуть сягати приміром, і 34-х тисяч гривень,
і кількох десятків тисяч євро, якщо автомобіль з надмірною вагою
проїде велику відстань.
Про ці суми водії будуть дізнаватися вже постфактум -
коли їхні роботодавці отримають «лист щастя» від «Укртрансбезпеки»,
на яку поклали контроль за станом доріг.
Проте усе це - розповіді про майбутнє.
Поки система автоматичного контролю ваги у русі
працює в тестовому режимі.
Їх аж дві на всю Україну, обидві – на Київщині.
І поки за перевантаження фур і руйнування українських доріг
водіїв карають по-старому.
Цей бетоновоз спершу перевіряють на пересувному комплексі «Укртрансбезпеки».
Причому двічі, бо одразу не можна зафіксувати
ще й показники ваги по осях  автомобіля.
Ще машину можуть перевірити на стаціонарних вагах.
Усі ваги показують різні цифри, але всі вони у межах норми.
Ми не вантажимо більше, ніж потрібно.
Ми знаємо вагу вантажу і так їдемо.
Якби виявили перевищення ваги, інспектори мали б зобов’язати водія
прямо тут розвантажитись і розділити всі товари по кількох інших машинах.
А потім - таки виписати штраф вже за новими підвищеними тарифами.
Але в те, що інспектори будуть належним чином виконувати закон,
вірять не усі водії.
Це державний лохоторон.
Хто як хоче, так і робить.
Їдуть зерновози по 35 тон, по  40 тон.
Ім можна їхати, так?
А тут 22 тони везеш, а вони кажуть, що перевантаж.
А зерновози йдуть. А він каже  - на бік, він пише тобі вже штраф.
А чому це так має бути ? Зерновозам можна, а нам не можна?
Підвищили, тільки не знаю для кого!
Якщо машини возили  перегрузи, так вони і возять!
Для кого підвищили, не знаю.
А  машини возять перегрузи, бо це або  машини депутатів
або тих, хто сидять в верхах
Ігор Василів наразі депутат від правлячої партії "Слуга народу".
А ще рік тому активно боровся в рідній Тернопільській області
проти вантажівок з надмірною вагою.
За його досвідом, жодні інспектори "Укртрансбезпеки"
чи то патрульної поліціі не здатні впоратися з креативом перевізників,
у арсеналі яких багато хитрощів, як обходити закони та не платити штрафи.
Коли я був активістом, ми доходили до смішних ситуацій.
Насправді, заїжджає перевантажений автомобіль
Перед вагою його блокують по джіпіесу.
Він стоїть,  в цей час не можна зупинити всі фури.
Всі фури їдуть далі, всі перевантажені, а він буде стояти, доки не закінчиться робочий день.
Його неможливо ні завести, нічого зробити.
Але інспектори "Укртрансбезпеки " заперечують, що теж промаху не дають.
Вони слухають рації водіїв, відслідковують їхні повідомленнями в різних месенеджерах.
В них є назва кожних постів.
В Миколаєві це "трактор".
В Дніпрі - "бик".
Це пам’ятники стоять, де поряд розташовані площадки контролю.
Проте частіше їм не до сміху.
Усіх порушників вони оштрафувати  не в змозі.
В  "Укртрансбезпеці " на всю Україні - лише 217 інспекторів.
З таким обмеженим штатом новий закон якісно навряд можна виконати.
- З урахуванням законодавства, що
8 годин робочий день, то для здійснення
цілодобового габаритно-вагового контролю необхідно
мінімум 3 зміни.
Три зміни по 2 чоловіки - це повинно бути
6 чоловік уже, а в нас у деяких областях
взагалі 6 чоловік інспекторського составу.
Тож в "Укртрансбезпеці" чекають на рішення уряду
про розширення штату. А також на тендери
щодо закупівлі нагрудних камер,
щоб дії інспекторів і водіїв фіксувалися,
адже нововведенням будуть раді аж ніяк не всі водії фур.
Навіть якби автоматичні системи контролю
допомагали інспекторам, Ігор Василів усе одно поки
не очікує великих надходжень у бюджет,
оскільки нового механізму стягнення штрафів
немає: Верховна Рада поки не затвердила.
- У законі має бути прописано так, щоб
не могли потім їхні юристи
високооплачувані насправді, юристи не змогли почати відсуджуватися,
бо багато є такого, коли в нас, навіть коли
держава звітувала останніх 5 років,
що ми зловили перегруз рекордний - 105  тон…
Якщо ви візьмете й подивитеся, чи були сплачені
ці штрафні санкції, - ні, тому що потім відсуджують.
Водій із Туреччини Саліх готує собі
смачний сніданок на Чернігівській трасі.
Трохи починає нервувати, коли йдеться
про нові штрафні санкції в Україні. Він розмовляє
трохи російською, трохи німецькою. І йому
навряд чи змогли пояснити, чому оштрафували
його машину, яка замість дозволених 40 тонн
заважила лише 38.
- У мене є штраф. Так, вже є.
Не знаю. Скільки саме, не знаю.
Саліх каже, що тепер з українськими інспекторами
буде розбиратися центральний офіс його компанії.
Українські водії визнають, що готові
поступово змінювати свою роботу.
І не лише тому, що теж хочуть їздити нормальними дорогами.
- А більше ми не грузимо. Навіть якщо просять, ми не грузимо.
А смисл?
- А для чого нам перегрузи?
Нам перегрузи не...
Не возим того, щоб машини не портить.
Тому що...
дорогі запчасті.
- Я на Європу їжджу, не доводилося, в мене все йде по контролю.
- Якщо на Європу, то під контролем?
- Там закон , тут ще...
Ще не дійшли ці закони сюди.
Європейські стандарти на українських дорогах -
глобальна мета уряду. Для цього планується
по максимуму розвантажити роботою
інспекторів "Укртрансбезпеки", встановити по всій країні
ще 115 систем автоматичного контролю ваги в русі.
Перш за все - на дорогах, якими возять вантажі
в бік морських портів і країн ЄС.